[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute messbar
guten abend und willkommen norbert
lehmann ist auch dabei für den sport ein
gegentor von mir und das sind einige
themen von heute
wie sinnvoll sind die neuen core ohne
regeln mediziner zweifeln an den
beschlüssen zur quarantäne
gastronomen fürchten neue einbußen wegen
zweig plus
gruppen für das regime in kasachstan
russland schickt weitere soldaten ins
land die lage dort ist unübersichtlich
und
naturgewalt im naturparadies ein vulkan
bricht auf den galapagos inseln aus die
einzigartige tierwelt ist bisher nicht
in gefahr
[Musik]
corona infizierte und ihre
kontaktpersonen dürfen künftig wieder
schneller raus und arbeiten gemusterte
kontaktpersonen müssen gar nicht mehr in
quarantäne
das haben bund und länder beschlossen um
flächendeckende personalausfälle zu
verhindern sehr sinnvoll sagen die
kommunen für medizinisch fragwürdig
hättest der marburger bund bundesweit
gab es auch heute wieder proteste gegen
die korona maßnahmen und gegen eine
allgemeine impfpflicht patricia
wiedemeier
in hamburg gab es heute die wohl größte
protestaktion rund 16.000 impfgegner und
corona zweifler soll es laut
polizeiangaben gewesen sein das motto
hier das maß ist voll kritik an den
beschlüssen der gestrigen bund länder
runde auch von der ärzteorganisation
marburger bund die quarantäne befreiung
für frisch geimpfte und genesene
kontaktpersonen sei medizinisch
fragwürdig wir fordern tatsächlich das
auch zweifach geimpfte und genesene
zumindest in diese verkürzte quarantäne
müssen wenn sie engen kontakt haben
insbesondere wenn sie mit einer
infizierten aktuell mit micr on
infizierten personen unter einem dach
leben zudem sei es nicht verständlich
dass keine pflicht zum tragen einer fft
zwei maske im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr beschlossen wurde
positives echo gibt es dagegen vom
landkreistag vor allem für die verkürzte
quarantäne die verkürzung der
quarantänezeit ist absolut notwendig und
sie scheint mir ein guter ausgleich zu
sein zwischen den medizinischen fordern
müssen einerseits und der
aufrechterhaltung der kritischen
infrastruktur andererseits dringend
nötig sei jetzt aber die einführung
einer allgemeinen impfpflicht das sieht
auch die opposition so und fordert dass
die regierung endlich ein gesetz vorlegt
die bundesregierung muss auch schon
einen vorschlag machen was das konkret
bedeutet in der umsetzung so über die
vorschläge haben dann werden wir darüber
beraten noch liegt kein gesetzentwurf
vor aber klar ist jetzt schon eine
allgemeine impfpflicht ist die zurzeit
umstrittenste maßnahme
bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas
fordert noch im januar im bundestag über
die allgemeine impfpflicht zu
debattieren das parlament müsse sich
gründlich mit dem komplexen und
kontroversen thema befassen sagte was
gegenüber der rheinischen post
impfpflicht für alle wie könnte sie
aussehen und welche rechtlichen zweifel
gibt es antworten darauf finden sie in
der zdf- heute- apple
auch das haben bund und länder gestern
gemeinsam beschlossen bundesweit zweig
plus für die gastronomie heißt wer ins
restaurant will muss geimpft oder
gelesen sein und braucht einen negativen
test nur gemusterte dürfen ohne test
rein allerdings bröckelt die einigkeit
sachsen anhalt will die regelung vorerst
nicht umsetzen und bayern will sie noch
prüfen in sechs bundesländern gilt zweig
plus bereits darunter auch rheinland
pfalz 27
die 2g plus kontrolle ist in diesem
mainzer kaffee schon routine wer in ein
lokal will und nicht gepostet ist muss
hier in rheinland pfalz schon seit gut
einem monat einen negativen test
vorlegen am anfang war das schwierig
weil die leute es einfach dreimal
überlegt haben ob es einen test machen
um kaffee trinken zu gehen und die woche
vor weihnachten und zwischen den jahren
hat sich das sehr gut eingependelt man
merkt mehr und mehr menschen werden
gewusst hat 2g plus in cafés bars und
restaurants das soll nun in fast allen
bundesländern kommen nicht aber in
sachsen anhalt katrin riesenbeck
betreibt in magdeburger in restaurant
dass die regeln hier lockerer bleiben
werde die gastronomie kaum retten sagt
sie für uns ist es halt auch so dass er
im moment auch tage dabei haben wir
keinen umsatz haben wo nicht ein gas
kommt zweig oder zweig plus im endeffekt
macht es nicht viel aus ob zweig plus
kommt das ist auch hier in bayern noch
offen in diesem hotel restaurant bad
aibling warten sie gespannt auf die
entscheidung also ich erhoffe mir dass
es nicht noch schlechter wird als es
momentan schon ist weil durch die 2g
regelung sind schon genug leute
ausgegrenzt oder abgeschreckt zum teil
und bei 2g plus fürchte ich wäre es
nicht mehr rentabel überhaupt nach dem
betrieb offen zu halten auch der hotel
und gaststättenverband glaubt dass viele
restaurants schließen werden zweige plus
sei kontraproduktiv dann wird sich das
geschehen ins private verlagert genau
dort wo die infektionsgefahr deutlich
höher ist dort wo man keine schutz und
hygiene konzepte hat und deshalb wird
das das infektionsgeschehen eher
anheizen stadt bremsen
doch befürworter von 2g plus hoffen auf
mehr sicherheit beim restaurantbesuch
und dass die poster kampagne auf diese
weise weiter in fahrt kommt und
das sind die aktuellen corona zahlen dem
robert koch institut wurden 55
1889 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
gemeldet 29
1497 mehr als vor einer woche 2 168
todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines tages
dazu die sieben tage incidents steigt
auf 300 35,9
mittlerweile sind mindestens 21 8
prozent der menschen die in deutschland
leben vollständig geimpft eine
auffrischungsimpfung haben
42,3 prozent erhalten
schlusslicht beim impfen ist nach wie
vor sachsen dort gibt es zu dem
verhältnismäßig viele radikale gegner
der korona maßnahmen anfang dezember
zogen einige mit fackeln vor das
privathaus der gesundheitsministerin
aber jetzt setzt die gegenbewegung in
sachsen ein zeichen aus dresden
berichtet franziska wunderlich
hunderte kerzen entzündet vor der
dresdner frauenkirche
sie sollen ein anderes licht auf sachsen
werfen als jenes in dass das land durch
teils gewaltsame proteste von
querdenkern und impfgegnern geraten ist
des aufbruchs
optimismus für das jahr 2022 auch senden
und vor allem auch mein gutes bild
wieder von der stadt und auch von
sachsen insgesamt
neben dem bekenntnis für ein friedliches
miteinander soll mit den kerzen auch an
die verstorbenen corona patienten
erinnert werden und
die korona familie betrifft uns alle und
ja es wäre schön wenn alle sicher etwas
solidarisch zeigen würden ja damals
anderes zeichen der stadt haben als
diese
mehr als 9.000 personen institutionen
und initiativen sind dem aufruf haltung
zeigen gefolgt entweder vor ort oder im
netz auch die staatlichen
kunstsammlungen haben unterzeichnet
dass dieses haus natürlich auch eine
haltung hat und manchmal gibt es auch
momente wo man dann die haltung zeigen
muss auch in dem die museumsleitung
heute kinder und jugendliche in die
historischen gemäuer des
residenzschlosses einlud um sich hier
impfen zu lassen begleitet vom
kinderchor der semperoper
[Musik]
als die musik war schön das hat spaß
gemacht das ist eine einstellung dazu
ist etwas einfacher als beim kinderarzt
also ich find die tour nicht wie die
anderen in drei wochen soll es die
möglichkeit geben sich hier dann auch
das zweite mal impfen zu lassen
und ich hatte eben einen zahlendreher
beim impfen drinnen natürlich sind
71,8 prozent der menschen hier in
deutschland vollständig geimpft ich
bitte das zu entschuldigen
während deutschland um eine corona
impfpflicht ringt hat italien sie in
teilen eingeführt dort gilt ab heute die
impfpflicht für über 50-jährige schweren
betroffen von der pandemie ist auch
wieder indien mit gut
140.000 neue infektionen heute der
höchste wert seit ende mai in der
hauptstadt neu delhi gilt über das
wochenende ein lockdown
wegen der krise in kasachstan stoppt die
bundesregierung ihre rüstungsexporte
dorthin im wert von 22 millionen euro
die lage in der ehemaligen
sowjetrepublik ist weiterhin instabil
nach einer woche mit gewaltsamen
ausschreitungen mehreren dutzend toten
und festnahmen in einem telefonat
sicherte der russische präsident putin
seinem amtskollegen in kasachstan
weiterhin unterstützung zu axel sturm
wieder schüsse wieder gewalt bilder die
aus almaty stammen sollen vom frühen
morgen die lage normalisiere sich sagt
der präsident die bilder lassen anderes
vermuten pokal jetzt sagt auch 20.000
angreifer hätten amati allein
heimgesucht auf twitter postete er unter
anderem keine gespräche mit terroristen
wir müssen sie töten
russlands armee ist inzwischen vor ort
auch soldaten aus armenien aus belarus
tadschikistan und kirgistan und heute
wird bekannt dass die kasachischen
behörden karim massimow auf festgenommen
haben er war zuletzt chef des
geheimdienstes unter präsident tokarev
verdacht auf hochverrat heißt es
präsident
öffentlichkeitswirksam die staatsspitze
um heute die festnahme des ex
geheimdienstchef zuvor war bereits die
seine regierung entlassen worden und
auch ex präsidenten nasarbajew musste
den vorsitz des sicherheitsrates abgeben
währenddessen versuchen die menschen an
ihr geld zu kommen und an flüssiggas und
benzin für ihre autos viele fassen nicht
was sich abspielt
ich wollte nur mal schauen aber sie
lassen niemanden durch sie schießen
in die luft jaja in die luft um mich zu
warnen geh weg haben sie gesagt
die zwischenbilanz der unruhen in
kasachstan dutzende tote eine unklare
zahl verletzter und landesweit rund 4400
festnahmen
in polen geht die opposition auf die
barrikaden die regierung hat eine
spionage-software eingesetzt die handys
auslesen kann das hat der chef der
regierungspartei peace zugegeben aber
nur zur verbrechensbekämpfung sagt
jaroslaw kaczynski das mit pegasus
unliebsame regierungskritiker überwacht
worden seien streitet er ab mehr aus
warschau von tom bloch es ist der chef
der pis partei jaroslaw kaczynski
persönlich der bestätigt was andere
regierungsmitglieder als fake news
abtaten polen besitzt die spähsoftware
pegasus tatsächlich laut polnischen
medien offenbar bezahlt vom
justizministerium aus einem fonds zur
verbrechensbekämpfung der minister räumt
den kauf der software ein es wäre eine
blamage für den polnischen staat wenn er
sie nicht hätte und der staat nicht
dafür sorgte dass sie den
strafverfolgungsbehörden zur verfügung
stehen die opposition wirft der
regierung aber vor nicht nur handydaten
von verbrechern aus gelesen zu haben
sondern auch die von politischen gegnern
um damit den wahlausgang 2009/10 zu
beeinflussen neben einer staatsanwältin
und einem anwalt soll auch der
oppositionelle senator christoph bresser
betroffen sein offenbar wurden seine sms
gestohlen und dann manipuliert in
staatsnahen medien veröffentlicht
sie haben es benutzt sie haben hunderte
personen abgehört es ging natürlich
darum in der opposition zu sammeln und
sie im wahlkampf zugang
bestätigt wird der verdacht von einer
forschungsgruppe der universität toronto
die den missbrauch der software
untersucht und für amnesty international
geht es dabei nicht nur um die
privatsphäre einzelner personen
dies ist eine sache die uns veranlasst
nach der stabilität und dem vertrauen in
demokratische prozesse in polen zu
fragen
viel lärm um nichts sagt jaroslaw
kaczynski ob ein untersuchungsausschuss
kommt ist offen und auch die
staatsanwaltschaft hat ermittlungen
bislang abgelehnt
sechs jahre gab der größte vulkan der
galapagos-inseln ruhe jetzt spuckt er
wieder lava und asche die galapagos
inseln liegen im pazifik fast 1000
kilometer von der küste ecuadors
entfernt zu ihren berühmtesten bewohnern
gehören die galapagos riesenschildkröten
wegen ihrer seltenen tier und
pflanzenarten zählt die inselgruppe zum
unesco weltnaturerbe
was der vulkanausbruch für menschen und
tiere dort bedeutet zeigt thomas garcia
der himmel glimmt über der insel isabela
ein morgenroth doch nicht die aufgehende
sonne sondern vulkan wolf zeigt hier
seine kraft spuckt blut gas und asche
seien rauch steigt fast vier kilometer
hoch leuchtenden aber frisst sich durch
die landschaft glühendes gestein
durchschneidet ein paradies schnell wird
klar bewohner sind nicht in gefahr
doch was ist mit den tieren ob teils
uralte riesenschildkröten oder die
äußerst seltenen nur hier lebenden rosa
leguane die fauna auf den galapagos
inseln ist einzigartig sie gehört zum
unesco weltnaturerbe
bedroht der vulkan nun die bedrohten
arten
am morgen haben wir festgestellt dass
die lava südlich vom krater abfließt das
heißt unsere tierwelt es den moment
nicht betroffen
keine entwarnung aber für einige rare
pflanzenarten
könnten blut und feuer zum opfer fallen
und vulkan wolf koch weiter noch geht
ihm sein heißer atem nicht aus
in der mitte und im südwesten
deutschlands heute dagegen ein kurzer
wintereinbruch für so manchen autofahrer
begann der tag in thüringen nicht
besonders gut betroffen auch die a9 es
gab viele unfälle zum glück nur
blechschäden ähnliches bild auf der a 3
der abschnitt zwischen wiesbaden und
limburg war über stunden gesperrt viele
lkw kamen mit schnee und eis nicht klar
mit schnee und eis hervorragend klar
gekommen ist francesco friedrich hat der
deutsche bob dominator der hat heute das
dutzend vollgemacht sein zwölfter
saisonsieg der rekordweltmeister gewann
beim weltcup in winterberg im zweierbob
und verbesserte dabei auch noch seinen
eigenen bahnrekord und das sogar gleich
doppelt denn mit anschieber alexander
schiller kann friedrich nach 54,8 9
sekunden im ersten lauf im zweiten auf
exakt dieselbe neue rekordzeit
unabhängig davon hat sich friedrich für
die olympischen spiele auch torsten marx
als anschieber im zweier festgelegt da
dieser erfahrener ist zum bereits
vierten mal in dieser saison zweiter
hinter friedrich wurde johannes lochner
gemeinsam mit florian bauer vor dem
kanadischen olympiasieger justine krebs
felix loch ist beim rodel-weltcup in
sigulda im einsitzer auf den zweiten
platz gefahren ja und im doppelsitzer
triumphierten die thüringer toni eggert
und sascha benecken
das ist ihr zweiter saisonsieg tobias
wendl und tobias arlt auf platz drei
vervollständigten den deutschen erfolg
beim weltcup in lettland und deutsche
erfolge die gab es auch beim weltcup der
nordischen kombinierer in val di firma
im ersten einzel wettbewerb des jahres
gab es am ende ein packendes deutsches
duell auf der zielgeraden um platz zwei
das vinzenz geiger ganz knapp vor eric
frenzel gewann sieger der österreicher
johannes lamparter
in der fußball-bundesliga hat hoffenheim
durch einen heimsieg den sprung auf
tabellenplatz drei geschafft jede
bisherigen ergebnisse des 18 spieltag
die tsg gewinns bezwingend augsburg mit
3 zu 1 freiburg und bielefeld trennen
sich 2 2 leipzig stück mainz souverän
mit 4 2 1 führt und stuttgart trennten
sich torlos 0 0 ebenfalls ein
unentschieden zwischen leverkusen und
union 22 das abendspiel frankfurt gegen
dortmund ausführlich zu sehen bei uns im
aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr und
bereits gestern verloren die bayern
gegen gladbach mit 1 2 die tabelle
münchen erster dortmund könnte heute
abend den abstand verringern hoffenheim
jetzt dritter freiburg einen platz
runter leverkusen fünfter union sechster
die zweite tabellenhälfte die beginnt
mit mainz stuttgart jetzt 15 augsburg
rutscht auf platz 16 und danach
unverändert bielefeld und schlusslicht
greuther fürth
19 fall novak djokovic der serbische
tennis star sitzt seit tag in melbourne
fest die behörden hatten ihm die
einreise zu den austrian open verweigert
es geht um seinen corona status nun
sollen djokovic anwälte weitere
dokumente vorgelegt haben die australian
open ohne ihn ohne novak djokovic für
seine anhänger vor dem ausreise hotel in
melbourne undenkbar laut australischen
medien deuten gerichtsdokumente nun auf
einen positiven corona test des tennis
stars am 16 dezember hin allerdings
zeigte er sich noch am tag nach dem pcr
test bei einem fototermin mit serbiens
tennis nachwuchs djokovic anwälte
berufen sich offenbar auf eine
information des verbands tennis
australia nach der im vergangenen
halbjahr genesene spieler ins land
einreisen dürfen ob dies auch für
djokovic gilt und er doch an den
australian open teilnehmen darf
entscheidet am montag ein gericht in
melbourne
die nacht bringt von westen her neuen
schnee und neuen regen wo es auch
tagsüber weiter schneit weiß gleich cut
johanna marietta slomka meldet sich mit
dem heute journal gegen viertel vor elf
wir danken für ihr interesse und
wünschen noch ein unbeschwertes
wochenende bis morgen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend endlich mal neuschnee auch
im flachland und jetzt in der nacht
kommt neuer schnee hinterher das geht
aber ganz schnell in regen über wie sie
hier sehen können der erreicht bis zum
frühen morgen fast schon den osten und
am längsten trocken bleibt es in dieser
nacht ganz im osten hier zwischen der
ostseeküste und ostsachsen sonst machen
sie sich wieder auf winterliche
straßenverhältnisse gefasst auf schnee
schneeregen schnee matsch bei starkem
wind aus südlichen richtungen die
temperaturen in dieser nacht sinken auf
plus 4 bis minus fünf grad schnee und
regen der nacht ziehen morgen über tag
weiter ostwärts dann ist es meist stark
bewölkt hin und wieder können sie aber
auch ganz schön die sonne sehen zum
beispiel an der nordseeküste oder auch
an der mosel es wird weiter schneien
besonders hier in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen bei temperaturen von ein
bis drei grad deutlich milder ist es
schon im westen jetzt schauen wir in die
kommende woche da wird sich diese
sturmtief über dem zentralen mittelmeer
nämlich nach osten verabschieden und bei
uns in mitteleuropa etabliert sich ein
hoch das bedeutet jetzt im winter nicht
unbedingt nur strahlenden sonnenschein
sondern es gibt häufig auch wolken und
nebel schnee fällt aber eigentlich nur
noch im südosten am montag schönes
wochenende